the session on what they don't teach in
Business School about entrepreneurship
having taught entrepreneurship at the
Stanford Business School for something
like 13 years I can tell you there's a
lot some of it we know we don't teach
and some of it we probably should teach
if we knew a little more about the
subject so I think it's a very pertinent
subject today so Mike why don't you
introduce yourself and tell us a little
bit about what you did I just remember
I've got a little bio here so if you
don't include things like an included
and if you if you do include things that
that aren't here I may question you
okay so it's like the Senate
investigation committee check except
you're not sitting out there I do get
lights flashing at me so I've been the
CEO and co-founder of for startups I was
very lucky with the first three one was
the first one was I started with $500 of
myself and each of my two partners put
in $500 we have $1,500 we started it in
my second year of Business School at the
business of the Stanford of the East
Coast in Boston
we we never raise venture capital it
started as a company called dial a fish
was when you could order groceries from
home was insane it was before the
internet and everything we eventually
sold it for we had to change direction
because that was not going to work into
a computer telephony tool we sold it for
thirteen million dollars a few years
later which was tiny for Silicon Valley
standards but you know a fair New
England return on the $1500 investment
the second company was direct hit which
was an internet search engine now we
ever heard of internet direct hit but we
were providing search results to
Microsoft AOL Lycos we're kind of a
behind the scenes provider and it was
the right time we grew to a market value
of 500 million dollars 500 days after we
launched it and we sold it in January of
2000 and then the third company was
Xfire which is an instant messenger
for PC video gamers spread virally we
got to about three million users two
years after launching we sold it for a
hundred million dollars to MTV and now
there's 15 million users by using it and
I'm now working my fourth one which I
could end up being I want to be four now
but it could be three and one because
you haven't sort of found the formula
for success on rube aruba's a travel
site so that's sort of my background and
what did you graduate from Harvard Oh
long long time ago I'm going to get into
numbers do i yeah the review well the
reason why is it's sort of interesting
to know the timing of your first venture
right because that was you say prior to
the internet yes but so you were you
were actually a leader in that others
came after you also didn't do very well
right ah so I will you may have been the
biggest winner in that whole space of
order include from home if we'd started
a different time well you you sold it
for thirteen million dollars can most
the other companies I know boss plan
right so win by default
um sure so um I decided I was gonna stop
aging it at age 31 so I graduated
Harvard from 1991 so I must have
graduate around age 11 so you can figure
out good alright thank you
sewer so I'm Nestle elasti and I started
life as an engineer I'm Iranian
originally and in my country if you're a
good student you either become a doctor
or an engineer so there was that was the
choice and I was scared of blood so off
I went into engineering school but it
was actually a really great background I
thought for Silicon Valley I didn't know
I would end up here but I did and I was
thankful for my parents for having
pushed me into engineering fast forward
five years of working
a technology company Advanced Micro
Devices I became a project designer
Project Lead went to business school and
learned that people can actually make
money selling pencils and that it
doesn't have to be semiconductors that
was my big learning from from business
school entrepreneurial activities at the
time were not as hot as they are now
what is good I graduate in 88 so I also
stopped aging at 30 a few years earlier
than yeah yeah and and I have to say
that my experience at Business School
was really eye-opening broadening but I
wouldn't say that I was focused on
necessarily becoming an entrepreneur it
seemed very risky at the time however
after I got out and experienced the
venture capital world for a couple of
years and then went on to work at Apple
which I consider really my formative
years at Apple and worked on a big
failure of a project called Newton which
was the original handheld device I came
to understand that I really needed more
freedom in my life and that the
corporate structure wasn't providing
that and I was stupid enough or naive
enough to say that I could do things on
my own so I started a long line of all
sorts of startups failures as well as
successes and ended up now running
juniors which is my first from
PowerPoint to funding to product startup
where I'm CEO founder and I'm growing
that business so that's a little bit
about me
as it was also the mother to daughter
yes I am and someone who is passionate
about trying to help those of you who
are thinking about entrepreneurship
learn more about it so that's why she's
here today let me add to that thank you
for bringing it up um I also want to
talk to the women in in the group if
you're interested afterwards about why I
believe entrepreneurship is actually a
very valid choice and
and and compatible with being a mother
so anyone who's interested in discussing
that I'm open to doing that the world
will tell you no it's 24/7 etc unless
you burn the midnight oil you won't be
successful I happen to have a different
story so if anyone is interested I'm
happy to share that great thank you
so we we talked to we've heard from two
people who actually had technical
backgrounds will give us your background
and what you're doing now next Chuck so
I graduated in 1999 from Kellogg and
I've been in the valley since then I've
done a combination of both startups and
venture capital activity so currently
I'm the CEO of Sequoia and Hummer
Winblad funded company called widget box
and I joined widget box two years ago
and before that I was a managing
director at Hummer Winblad and spent six
years in the Metro capital business so
since I got out of business school I've
had kind of the opportunity to see both
of entrepreneurs in action as a venture
backer and thinking through business
models and deciding who to finance and
who not to finance and then also having
decided that to become an entrepreneur
myself and it's only recently I even
consider myself what quite honestly but
the last couple years of running a small
startup that's not profitable makes you
one I think it's been it's been a very
interesting time to run run a company so
now I'm definitely excited to be here
today and kind of share my thoughts
about what Business School taught me
what it didn't taught me to teach me
about you know how to lead a company
bring products to market sell etc and
Chuck's right like in terms of
backgrounds I went to Harvard study East
Asian Studies and finance and started my
career actually in Asia so I worked in
Hong Kong and Singapore spoke Mandarin
Chinese and thought I was going to be
part of the Asian miracle and but so
that so I've done I'm not coming it from
an engineering background in other words
and so part of you know one of the
questions today I think is how two MBAs
and finance people fit in to a culture
that's really driven by by engineers as
opposed to business types and kind of
the MBA being a joke as opposed to
something good
so you know I'm happy to be here and
look forward to good discussion and one
of things will if I'm if I'm correct and
reading this and listening to you you
see you formed a you effect you joined
widget box after it had actually been
founded that's correct so there were
three technical founders they'd actually
raised ten million dollars before I got
from you some from me I was the seed
phone answer and then Sukhoi did the a
round and then Frank Jones and Tommy
Bardell at Northgate could the be round
and at that point they were looking for
a CEO and they they did a nine-month
search and the last guy that we made the
offer to I told myself at the dinner if
this guy doesn't take the job I'm doing
it he didn't take the job so yeah so so
some different paths here I mean
starting their own company going out and
tried to find the idea put the team
together versus joining a start-up after
his head the initial founders the way we
want to start this is to is to ask them
a little bit about what led them to
decide to follow an entrepreneurial path
because many of you are in business
school are not in business school you're
thinking about this and you've got a set
of ideas in your head as to what it's
going to be like to be an entrepreneur
and then what has been the biggest
surprise for them as they joined the
entrepreneurial world so you've got a
vision what led you to do this and then
what's been the biggest surprise once
you once you jumped in let's start with
Mozilla um so I think I touched on that
for me they my job was such big part of
my life that unless I was very creative
and had the freedom to do what I wanted
to do didn't have to explain myself too
much I was unhappy so I thought that a
smaller environment less bureaucratic
environment would would afford that
I wanted to be my own boss
and kind of live and die by the
decisions that I made I also like
adrenaline I like living on the edge
I like being pushed to make decisions I
felt that I had too much cushion at
Apple frankly my decisions really didn't
make a difference
the juggernaut was going on and I was
doing my best but you know where was my
contribution really so those were some
of the reasons that I decided to jump
into the entrepreneurial pool the
biggest surprise though and this
probably you all are smarter than I was
I am an immigrant so I always thought of
myself as someone who can do anything
just just give the problem to me I'll do
it I'll take care of it I really never
put too much emphasis or attention on
partners and I learned the lesson the
hard way that in a start-up environment
the biggest surprise for me was how much
you needed partners just like you can't
have it well you can't have a baby on
your own I suppose you could adopt one
and maybe that's what you did coming in
late as a CEO I don't know you know the
analogy stops there but but but I you
know I cannot emphasize the importance
of partners and I cannot emphasize how
much I was lacking in that dimension and
how much I wish had I done things a
different way to go back and make ideas
joint ideas as opposed to my idea so
that was the biggest surprise for me
thinking about a partner this is the
founding partner or you thinking about a
partner in terms of somebody in the
supply chain or oh pardon or more yeah
and and I also just let me briefly say
that I think my experience in Business
School told me what I was good at not
what I was lacking and so I if I were to
do it again I would emphasize a lot what
I'm lacking so that that defines type of
partner you'll be looking for so more on
that here's the discussion goes that way
okay will yeah for me I think it was
just the combination of a lot of
different variables but if you think
about where we live today right now in
this valley it's almost like how could
you not do it you know if not now when
you know and this is a the whole
ecosystem here is geared towards
risk-taking testing yourself there's a
whole you know obviously a huge base of
institutional venture capital support
legal systems are here and it really
came down to I remember doing investment
when I was investment side about how to
test semiconductors and at the time
there was the state of the art was
testing a quarter of the wafer and then
it was half the wafer and then finally
this breakthrough the test the full
wafer and I feel like entrepreneurship
is a full wafer test it's it's testing
every part of who you are it's testing
your passion your endurance your
perseverance your leadership skills your
sales ability you know it it and I just
felt that if I was 65 looking back on my
career I would never forgive myself for
living in this environment at this time
and not testing the whole wafer you know
and so venture capital is a great job
but it's it's literally it's a research
job you know we're in it's a job where
you make investment decisions and I
always felt when I met with the
entrepreneurs oh my god these guys you
know I admire them so much and they just
got to the cent point right I couldn't
imagine not doing it what you jumped in
what was the biggest surprise biggest
surprise was it being okay that you
don't have all the answers and trusting
and process to help you get to an answer
like I really thought because as an
investor you're hypothesis-driven you
believe that you're making investment
based on the following characterization
a B and C therefore D and as soon as you
start running a company you realize none
of those hypotheses - work and and your
because the venture guy you're paid to
have an opinion when they say we'll
what's your opinion on this deal you
have an opinion and also I realize like
[ __ ] I don't even I didn't know what to
do now like and realizing that that was
a very unnatural feeling because I find
myself and always know
of you and realizing now I don't know I
don't and we we basically live in the
context this is we had no idea how to
make money none and like dealing with
that and accepting that and then
realizing like well how are we going to
get out of this problem and just
deciding that okay I ran when Nick Saban
won the national championship he said
that hey we believe in process not
results at Alabama and what does that
mean what he meant was that if you know
how to block you know how to play
defense you know how to these things you
just play the game and then you trust
the process to help you get to the
result that you want but so rather than
a random act of heroism where you're
going to have this flash of genius
that's going to make you rich just
deciding to slowly steadily clawed your
way in a predictable way where you're
going and then trusting that that's
going to help you arrive at the right
answer as opposed to a priori saying I
have the answer now we'll just make that
happen that was a really hard transition
from you know being a investment
hypothesis-driven thinker to a process
driven thinker Mike out of engineering
school I went worked at political he's a
huge aircraft company and one of the
projects I got to work on was a
solar-powered racecar and it was a
totally cool job we raced across
Australia from Darwin to Adelaide and
this car before we built this car the
fastest again this was a long time ago
the fastest solar powered cars we're
going maybe 20 miles an hour maybe 22
miles an hour and we built the car that
could go 55 miles an hour forever just
on sunlight which is from an engineering
perspective like this amazing
accomplishment and we won the race and
we came back and I remember clears ever
my boss saying that's amazing you know I
just want to let you know the average
race at Hughes Aircraft Company is 6%
you're going to get 6.5 percent this
year and just the feeling at that moment
of you know your faith being in your own
hands was just like ok this is not going
to work I was also fired between between
first and second year at business school
I went worked at the consulting company
and at the end of the summer everyone
got an offer to come back except for me
and they fired me because I scowled at
people senior to me
in the firm and they told me that I
admire them for at least telling me that
but you know talk about wanting to be in
control these are all sort of strong
influences and and one other things were
how do you get into entrepreneurship I
was I was interviewed on Japanese TV
actually and I said well I think one of
the key test is how do you feel at nine
o'clock on Sunday night if you feel like
oh you know I was a great weekend
looking forward this week uh school
projects that's one thing but if you
feel like man I can't believe the
weekends over I'm original not looking
for work it's time to change well they
show this on Japanese TV and actually
showed it at nine o'clock on Sunday
night and apparently they got flooded
with 12,000 phone calls to the
switchboard to whatever saying yes we
need to get a new job so those are my
influences on doing do startup and the
biggest surprise for me at the risk of
Chuck's wrath because this is one of
those been said things yeah in terms of
I believe the most important things are
a small team with high morale is really
hard to defeat and you can we had to
change three out of my four companies
had to change the original idea
completely failed and had to change to a
new idea and that was a surprise to me
it wasn't so much the quality of the
original idea but was the quality of the
team and the morale of the team that I
think were the key things yeah
interesting so similar to Mozilla's
point that you need a team and you need
a high performance team because let me
just generalize a little bit what what
you just said Mike there are very few
companies that start off heading here
and just go like that
most of them go like this even if they
get there and many more go like this and
end up over here and the question is how
do you how do you do this sometimes
what's called the art of small boat
sailing any of your sailors you know you
tack back and forth and a good team is
though it's the way to do it yeah
so now we're going to we're going to
sort of turn a little bit to thank you
very much we're going to turn a little
bit to lessons learned and and to start
off just asking each one of the
panelists so what what are the two key
lessons one or two key lessons that have
been important to your success lack of
success you know if there have been
failures you know you learn more from
failures often than from successes and
how and where did you learn them and
then we're going to kind of after we
leave that we'll come and talk about
reflecting back on the your business
school experience and to find out so
what you think was most important about
your business school queries so let's
start with what are one or two key
lessons that have been important to your
success lack of success in your
entrepreneurial career how and where did
you learn them and let's get started
with us let's start with will
I would say the kind of I don't repeat
myself a little bit but I think what
Mike said is also really important to
like you know Andy comas are about the
book Plan B and it basically the same
point Chuck made about tacking back and
forth it's a it's being having a smart
high-energy team that learns really
rapidly what the signals the market are
giving it and you know we had a thesis
about a business and now we're on like
thesis for I think probably in
recognizing that like another I remember
Chuck used to be on the board of Conan
the founder Connor told me once when I
was thing about starting a company he
said listen the first steps the hardest
but once you start you're just on a
journey in a process and then and I
think that's right like so just
beginning to work be very very
aggressive about it but the same time be
very flexible as a team about how to
tack based on what you're hearing so
theses around revenue or monetization or
customer acquisition its market segment
positioning all that it should be taken
with degree of flexibility so that you
can reconstitute yourself and then being
able to work with investors is really
critical around that because investors
again going back to my original premise
about difference between startups and
investing investors are thesis-driven so
if you say we're going to go do this and
we're I'm raising money for this purpose
and we're going to attack this market
this way we're going to characterize
revenue model this way and then the
first board meeting you're like well
that's not what didn't work you know
having the ability to have that
conversation with them so they're with
you through the journey as opposed to
being surprised by the tack and so I
would say being able to work down with
your team and try to tack the mark and
then learn and then the other challenge
has been how do you work back up with
your investor group to basically say
okay well here's what we're seeing in
the market here's the data points here's
how I'd characterize those
here's why I think we need to move
direction a little bit and then making
that an open conversation so they become
part of the solution as opposed to like
critically observing your problem so I
don't know if that makes any sense but
the lesson is be ready for changes of
course and embrace them yeah and also
have the courage to go back to your
investor group and explain to them this
is not that this company is not doing
what they invested in yeah your your
point your point about as an investor
you've got a thesis and you're investing
in a market and if at the first board
meeting you come back and say oops sorry
guys I just took your ten million
dollars but right we're not going there
right and the other thing I really
learned I think and I say this with all
due respect is like vesser's are
extremely opinionated mock you know like
alpha male type people typically and
they and they have lots of opinions the
other thing I learned was to acknowledge
and be respectful and listen to all of
them without being overly reactive to
respond the particular one of them like
what I mean by that is they're gonna say
you know you should do this this this
and this and at first I'd be like I
could you know I'd go back and be like
okay well that just makes sense why
would I do that and but I was I over I
so there's a fine line I guess between
having an open conversation and
investors being extremely respectful of
their opinion because CEOs and don't
listen to their board get fired
relatively quickly in my experience so
you listen but then you still are in
charge and so you have to decide how you
incorporate their feedback make them
feel like they've been heard without
making decisions that you go against
your own gut feel or what you think the
business should really do that's
something that's also hard to learn I
think I just so you were he was an
investor with a firm called Hummer
Winblad one of those two was an Winblad
so let me change a little bit the alpha
male 2 very determined and opinionated
yes how's that that's very very fair all
right
wait so for me one of the golden rules
is speed is the ultimate weapon and I've
learned that in a good way in a bad way
I have all these little sayings I think
the probability of any business
development deal ever happening declines
by 10% every day it doesn't close and I
really believe that so you know Mike
week we closed the Microsoft deal with
direct hit where our results were shown
on the Microsoft search result page and
that deal was done in in less than 10
days and I think if it stretched on to
you know six weeks or something we never
would gotten done same with AOL do
I've just seen through my you know
history which ones closing which ones
don't
same thing with with raising money I
think I've raised seven rounds of
financing and six out of the seven had a
sign term sheet the same day I pitched
and I think if you stretch it out longer
all these questions and second thoughts
and more market research and whatever
comes up and even closing employees
someone comes in for an interview will
do due diligence checks while they're
still interviewing other people in the
company and before they leave the
building we'll give them an offer if we
like them and we'll say are you ready to
accept and they're like floored right
now we say you know yeah and then we say
okay I understand we don't want to rush
you sleep on it let us know nine o'clock
tomorrow morning but we get a lot of
those people and if we don't
I've seen people you've spread out and
then you lose them also launching
products all of my companies we launched
it we launched a product within three
months three and a half months of
starting the company and then you it's
not a very full-featured product but you
get the feedback from the mark and
everything so speed for me is far in a
way that the most important lesson I
learned so one of the points you made
there what had to do with the with
raising money and and signing the deal
the same day you you pitched and it's
were you able to do that the first time
out let's assume that these people are
all going to be the first time out yeah
so um
people always ask that and so let me
just say part of the part of the part of
the reason all of us I think here are
doing this is
for aspirational so sort of get you guys
you know motivate and excited so some of
these things may seem like I can't
believe that but it's sort of a goal to
go after but actually direct Jo Fisher
Jurvetson my second company so I had one
under my belt 13 million dollar one we
pitched them at 8:15 on a Tuesday
morning in April of 1998 and we got a
signed term sheet from them by 4:30 and
the way you do that anyone in this room
can do that I think some of the
techniques are you come into that
meeting with what I call an if-then
contract an if-then contract I go get a
customer for the product and make this
amazing claims like if we can provide
search results in 50 milliseconds that
80% of your users think our results are
better than your current results would
you buy them for $1.00 per thousand and
almost anyone will say yeah okay so they
sign a letter or whatever and and that
walk into the Draper future person with
this letter now there's all sorts of
caveats and clauses and no legal
contract but at least Trevor Fisher says
okay the you know market risk has been
eliminated he's got a customer and also
you walk into that meeting with sort of
how you're going to build a product
here's the Gantt chart here's the people
here's the three people I'm going to
hire I've already talked to them they've
already committed to join here's the you
know the database schema DFG doesn't
know whether the scheme is right or not
right or it's really going to take six
we've at least they think okay this
person seems to know where they're going
and so it's much easier for them to say
okay yeah and of course you also play
competitive pressure I always do my
meetings I'm meeting you know wills been
on the receiving side of this probably I
meet with three VC's in the same day and
I say it's moving fast and I'm actually
expecting a term sheet by five o'clock
today and sometimes they'll call me back
the next day and say we're in and I say
it's gone and they're like what do you
mean it's gone I say I told you five
o'clock and they say but all
entrepreneurs say that I say well
sometimes it is gone so I think if you
just project this if you project this
you can get it done and a lot of times
you know the venture capitalists will
sense this and they say wow this is this
is moving who are you dealing with
Draper on that day yeah I had Tim Steve
and John all in the room at 8:15 but
they are a group that can and does and
do make a quick decision so that was
that was pretty good
let's see who every test in the zone
yeah Wow
I'm floored I want you on my board my
experience has been very different the
small sailboat analogy I think
corresponds to our journey definitely
with juniors the company I'm leading
right now it was different with circles
this was late 90s you know 98 99 we
raised 27 million dollars and it was
very much of this quick you know Now or
Never but I guess my biggest lesson is
that you shouldn't give up and if 9
o'clock at night on Sunday you still
feel that you have the passion it's an
it's an affair that's not finished if
you're still coming up with good ideas
then keep on at it even if you don't
have the term sheet right so so
persistence always pays and it's kind of
what we'll was saying about the process
be very focused on what you're doing
where you are in the process and don't
give it up don't let people derail you
because they will try to the other
lesson I learned is that maybe I'm too
much of an engineer I I really don't
have it in me to go and Bluff like that
yes you do yes I need you as a coach I
will urge all of you to find a mic and
learn from seriously
there have been board members and my
company that have told me you did this
and this is how you spoke about it I
think it's also perhaps not too fine a
point on it
a female characteristic we you know yeah
you were expecting me to do this right
why should I even brag about it as
opposed to because you're dealing most
of the time with these alpha males that
are I characterize them as lions right I
am an ant
you know I build
and then I face the lion and the lion
just basically all he does all day long
is sit under the shade watch whoo that
looks like a good prey over there attack
and then when the lion is attacking Mike
Mike is like whoa I've got three other
lions coming quick whereas me I'm okay
so we're laughing about this but this is
a serious point find out if you're an
ant
get yourself a lion partner somewhere if
you're a lion get yourself an ant
partner right because both are necessary
and that the combo is really unbeatable
the combo is what lets you do the speed
right and the ant and the line better
trust each other you don't look like me
yeah yeah yeah I know you went lipstick
yeah I know but I have I have a brain I
can help you no um let me also share
since I've got the audience laughing I
think I have permission here I was six
months pregnant with my second daughter
Amazon made an offer for the company I
was at he circles at the time for 250
million dollars two hundred forty five
million dollars to be very precise
imagine second child belly comes out
much faster I am this big and I'm
literally jumping up and down on the
table saying to the CEO take it take it
take it and he looks at me he says
you're not an entrepreneur you really
don't have the balls an entrepreneur
will say no to then I'm like now this is
245 million dollars don't say no we sold
that company for 13 million dollars to
classmates.com
months from that point right after you
know whatever February of 2008 full of
2000 right so at that point I really
felt this small I'm like oh yeah that's
right
you know I'm pregnant and my hormones
I've gotten the better of me and I'm
definitely not an entrepreneur that's
why I'm working for this guy as a vp of
marketing
I may have all these ideas I may know
where I'm going but yep I'm not an
entrepreneur don't let ever the world
tell you that even if you're six months
pregnant all right seriously stick to it
go to the board do whatever you need it
you know because sometimes right people
come in different packages and don't let
the world tell you that you need to look
different
anyway I stuff and there's a there's a
female intuition and some of these
things I think that's very important
I'll tell you one other story hotmail
Sabir Bhatia had an offer from Microsoft
for 250 million dollars severes from
India Sabir called home he's talking to
his father he said we just had an offer
for 250 million dollars from Microsoft
his father says that is really great he
says I turned him down
father hangs up nanosecond later his
mother's on the phone saying sabirah
call that man back and tell him you'll
take that offer they took the offer
the stories that are being leather denim
and Steve Jurvetson was on the board
saying go take you off take the are yeah
well so let's turn out to a to business
school education and how that might or
might not have helped prepare you for
your work
in general and in specific instances
sort of in general but then that did or
didn't and then what were the most
valuable classes you took and what
classes didn't you take that you wish
you had taken and I guess we'll start
with will okay I thought about this
quite a bit I I guess I have three
comments that I thought about this is
more about what I didn't learn the first
is that risk is really relative people
think that doing startups is risky my
lot of the guys when I look back I went
my tenth this plus past year went to
Merrill Lynch Morgan Stanley BCG
McKinsey they all got fired all of them
and fired in two different waves the
first in 2002 and then again in last
year there's no such thing as a safe
haven in this economy people will cut
jobs as soon as they decide and by the
way you're like a number in some
budgeting exercise the CFO says we got
to cut heads you know fifteen percent
there's like alright take this whole
department out so just first thing I
think is just there's no such thing as a
safe place so if you're going to take
risk which you are whether you realize
it or not you might as well be in
control of your own destiny that's the
first thing that that I think a lot of
my classmates got wrong and by the way
when your ten-year Merrill Lynch vet and
you get whacked in New York City in the
meltdown of a financial market what are
you going to do nin you're just screwed
if you're an entrepreneur and Silicon
Valley it doesn't work out there'll be
plenty of things to do I guarantee you
the second thing is I really think
Business School's over teach how
rational organizations are they
basically basically make up this thing
that business every business is some DCF
model or some rational exercise and then
everyone gets around they make a logic
based decision about how what
when I first got out of the business
school I remember going into meetings
and going what the [ __ ] just happened
like how did that decision just get made
it makes no sense whatsoever and I
literally was like this is so weird I
was like disoriented for like weeks and
just like I don't understand how
anyone's making their decisions like no
one's even doing any analysis they don't
understand what they're talking about
and I read this book and it was kind of
a cliche but it basically said there's
two types of companies there's companies
that are idea driven where they're flat
they're merit-based and people they're
generally engineering companies a lot of
ways and they make decisions based on
rational logic and then there's people
driven companies that are driven by
politics and personal affiliations and
logic has nothing to do with it there
may be this kind of pretend that there's
a process but basically there's some
decision that gets made based on who
knows who or this or that and also and
it gets announced to the company and
generally if you work in those companies
everyone goes well what is going on and
I worked in a lot of people Paulo
political based organizations and and as
a MBA a business person I just was
completely dumbfounded by how companies
were working and I think that there's
you know there's like OB and people talk
about that but really I think one of the
challenges about business and general
economics or finances people presume
logic is the basis for how large
companies make decisions and all we have
to do is look at washing dc2 realize
it's not true the last thing I would say
is some for some reason business schools
are prejudiced against sales and like
there's I guarantee when you graduate
none of your classmates and become
salespeople and yet John Thompson John
Chambers San Paolo tsommo the guys who
run Siebel yeah John morgridge Steve
Ballmer
ran sales or Microsoft sales people run
the world you know like they are the
guys that go in like and there's it's
very rare that a marketing person is
going to run Cisco or IBM you know it's
salespeople so why is it the business
schools
don't embrace sales and sales cultures
and variable based compensation like
alright we're going to pay you 100 but
you can make 300 if you knock it out
well MBAs right now I just want a 125
and a little bit of variable that's like
why like if you're good and you can sell
then you should go and sell and
certainly whether you're selling to
raise money or selling your product like
sales is the heart of everything we do
and I just wish that someone had said to
me like go become a sales guy you know
or like learn sales or sales management
or like it's kind of like this dirty
thing like I will do product management
we'll do business strategy oh and then
there's someone's going to sell it well
who you know and if you're going to
manage sales people probably good to do
that so I I just don't get that part of
it and then why am I saying that I'm
done really quickly MBAs all have the
same mental frameworks for how they make
decisions and when you go into a company
you have to you get almost challenged a
little bit like so like you wonderful a
visual designer they're very creative
and they think in terms of pictures and
and in InDesign and then engineers are
very logic and architectural driven they
won't understand scale and all the other
things and when you do a lot of group
work a business school everyone's kind
of sharing a common framework because
they're teaching you a framework method
of decision making and then you get into
a company and you realize there's a lot
of this communication polymer like I
just personally not understand how they
think it makes no sense what they're
saying to me well that's because they're
looking at the problem completely
differently than you and I would say the
other thing I wish I'd done more in
Business School is do cross discipline
work like with other people not in my
school and I think the d.school here is
a great example of that where you can go
work with some creative designers and
some engineers and and you can really
realize that to solve a problem with
people from different disciplines
requires a degree of flexibility and how
you communicate and how you think about
it
and that was a real shock to me too and
you end up like I have a color view of
work for me to designers and right
whenever I talk to them I realize like
wow I don't they're like picking in from
this problem from such a different
vantage point than me but yet it's a
very valuable the way they're thinking
and they're better
than I am so those are all things that I
wish I'd learned more of I suppose um so
a while ago I had this this dream this
fantasy like gosh I wish I had this
magical power that I could get my
company to work I could control the
brain of someone I'm trying to get a
business development deal with you know
get inside get Google to do this get
Google to up you know change my page
rank or whatever and I'm trying to get
around to supporting wills point that I
then I realized you actually can and
that's through this this persuasion this
charisma this sales technique that I
think is the most important thing CEOs
do one way that I got a lot of
experience was in my first company we
were selling this software product 500
other software product over the
telephone and there were three people in
the company and we just gotten this
article in this magazine and sure enough
300 people called in the next two days
saying yeah we want to get the product
we don't even have it finished yet we
were a little bit jump the gun and so we
you know we created this database and we
started to put ever his name down and
call him back and then more people would
call in about the product so in the
beginning out of every hundred calls you
know I would take their information down
I would send up a brochure and I you
know I'd say okay I'll follow up or
something like that it basically was
closing nothing in 10 weeks later out of
every hundred calls I could get 33 of
them to give me their credit card number
by the end of the call and you just
learn to say well look you know we have
a 30 day money-back guarantee so why
don't you just give me your credit card
I'll send it to you then you can just do
the tutorial if you don't like it why do
you why they want to spend time reading
the brochure why don't we just have the
product in your hand and you can try
different techniques and different
approaches and learn which ones work and
the other thing I think that happens
that's very powerful is when you ask for
something huge something you think is
maybe a little bit outrageous and
someone gives it to you it's a very
eye-opening experience when you say to
AOL you know why don't you put our
search results right here and
split the revenue 5050 with us and when
they say okay you're like oh my goodness
you know there are some other analogies
I could give maybe probably not
appropriate in this environment but
where if you go for something you think
is maybe unattainable and sometimes they
say yes it's a very powerful experience
and it makes you try more often so good
okay so I I say that Business School
should require every student before
graduating to sell ten dollars worth of
goods ten dollars I second your point
and I'm going to move on selling is
underestimated and it is hard to get ten
dollars out of a person believe me it
doesn't matter the age doesn't matter
the size so in our company at juniors we
started as a free service we debugged it
and then realize that we have a long way
to go for this market to realize and we
better have some money coming in so we
turned it into a subscription service
and the amount of effort and thinking
that went into this exercise I can write
books about but the net result of it is
that we became the the masters of our
own universe if you will it's a very
small business but it is self-sustaining
right so importance of sales I can I can
highlight it enough similarly I thought
that in Business School my biggest
learning was on organizational behavior
just because I love to learn more about
people and how minds work and accounting
because I knew nothing about it right so
it does where the courses that attracted
me the most and I learned the most from
ah I think there is an overemphasis at
least in my years I'm sure things have
changed on maximizing revenues and
profits as opposed to maximizing value
and that's a critical question that
and the reason for it I think goes a
little bit to the fact that all of us
living in us capitalist society and so
variety I don't know what the reason is
but we always think bigger is better
and I'm not sure if that's the case for
everyone so understanding on the
spectrum of very very very small - very
very very large where your idea product
mentality personality wish for life you
know whatever where that fits I think
we'll start with the question what am i
maximizing certainly you can't create
Cisco just maximizing value although
some would argue that if value wasn't
maximized in some form or fashion
Cisco wouldn't be created we can have a
debate about which one comes first but
at the end of the day the question that
I faced as a CEO in my company right now
is what am i maximizing right certainly
I'm not maximized a number of people
coming to the site and registered
members because I'm putting in front of
them in 1995 barrier right subscriptions
give me money otherwise you can't use
the product but I'm maximizing the fact
that I know the people that I have are
going to pay this money because there is
a pain that I solve for them that's
that's what I'm maximizing right now so
so so on that another point on scale
when I was at Apple I was so ignorant I
would look around and say oh so stupid
this is so big and they don't really see
the value of my great ideas you know
what what is going on I was like here
it's like hey I'm an MBA use me you know
I'm smart I can do etc um but if you end
up in a big company please do me a favor
take the time to learn about scale you
know just watch it just watch how
organizations are bill watch how
products are shipped just watch it
because there are a lot of lessons that
you learn that you don't know where did
when
and where they're going to come handy
but they well I guarantee you so scale
it's kind of if you don't understand it
like I was when I was at Apple it's easy
to poopoo it and just say I'm just going
to go be an entrepreneur but if you pay
attention and learn from scale then you
can be a better entrepreneur anything
and I will harp once more again learn
where you are week I think in business
school because it's such a selective
program at Stanford people that come in
we all felt we were the chosen and the
school does nothing to diminish that
right what we're continuously pumped at
the very same time that I was going
through Business School my husband my
now husband and boyfriend was going
through a ph.d program at Stanford and
every day he was told how stupid he is
seriously he was writing a thesis he was
doing cutting edge work he was doing
modeling like you wouldn't believe and
every day they were telling me you came
short you came short yeah and every day
I was just for sitting in these great
chairs I was being told I'm wonderful
and and and so what happens is that you
really I think gravitate towards what
your strong act as opposed to finding
out what you're weak at and you know you
may you may be fine you know I'm good at
talking so I'm just going to keep on
talking I may not be very good at
thinking or understanding people's
feelings I'm just going to let another
person do that that's certainly a
strategy nothing wrong with that but if
you want to be a more holistic manager
and more well-rounded entrepreneur I
would definitely pay attention to the
negative space and what it is that you
don't do well and why and how can you
how can you be for that thank you so
we've got a couple other questions that
we can throw out here to the panel but
let's just open it up here see if there
any questions for the audience
mentioned financing on your on your own
growing organically and I actually study
the number business is one which we have
32 partners who each mortgage our house
we have many dollars and the company is
now the biggest company in the United
States in this particular field
anybody comment on that I never they've
got any debt to finance anything in any
business anybody want to if not we will
and I can yeah
I can start good uh so my first one was
this self financed with the fifteen
hundred dollars we never raised debt or
equity from investors um it's quite
painful to run a company with $1,500 in
invested capital it reduces your
flexibility about having any computers
for example in the company so I don't
think you have to raise venture money
but it's a sort of an optimization
decision the fastest way to get there a
lot of times is to raise venture money
now I actually haven't raised a lot of
venture money direct it started with one
point four million dollars and Xfire
start with 1 million dollars so I think
you can do just fine with first with see
I'm even evident Inc the coal in Silicon
Valley even small amounts like a million
dollars you can you can do quite fine
with that that question right here yeah
I thank you my name's Eric I'm a first
year me and you have an ethics class in
an OB class and one of those
talking a lot about eyes
which is how we're here at Levi's and
and I'm constantly struggling with that
and then also looking at
entrepreneurial spirit was like head
down get it done like how do you there's
a little bit of talk about attacking and
reacting to the market but how do you
reconcile your own
byah season with also just moving
straight forward ahead my biases you
mean in terms of thinking about what
what consequences might be of a
particular action or are you thinking
about biases against entrepreneurship or
for entrepreneurship how do you deal
with your personal your your your
personal might call prior priors in
terms of how the world works yeah
anybody wanted I'll take that um so I
came in with my biases about where the
direction of the product should be and
it was fortunate that I had team members
that helped me see how the market was
reacting what was good and bad and we
switched that but I had very strong bias
and I I'm of the school that says you
know if you don't believe it nobody else
will believe it right so in that I drove
really hard and then people kept on
presenting me with data here's how it's
not going to work
other times I haven't done so well so
it's a continuous struggle but you know
one of the things I do at the end of
every day I allow 10 minutes to just sit
and it's amazing the things that occur
to you and to me in those 10 minutes I
would highly recommend you doing that
because those types of answers don't
come by sitting and thinking about it
you know what I mean is you just need to
let them percolate a little bit and then
the answer will be self-evident but if
you don't believe as an entrepreneur
nobody else will believe so the only
thing I found a
that's really been helping me through
that is being very authentic with people
and you know you think of entrepreneurs
maybe uh you know there's a fine line
between being like constant salesman
optimism and being authentic you know
and if you've all met penalty people you
go this guy's such a snake-oil sylvans
you don't believe it and so what I found
it's been really helpful is having
access to people where I can just be
completely honest with and let my guard
down and say here's I'm really
struggling with this and I have you know
you know obviously if you're a leader
you know you don't want to panic people
by making it seem like it's hopeless or
anything but if you can have access to
people who can you can jet just
generally lay out your concerns and get
feedback you wrecked you really find out
that what happened to be worse I went to
David Horne X conference the lobby in
Hawaii and it was this great for almost
like just the people sharing pain
basically it was Willie but in a way
that was very cathartic in the sense
that you realize like everyone goes
through this even people who are super
confident super accomplished have gone
through very dark moments and and
they've been you even though you're
going through that and you're concerned
you can font you can get recharged by
just it you know having that kind of
conversation then be able to go back and
get stronger to deal with you know your
issues like any kind this okay the other
questions right here Mozilla you mention
it over things
I'm interested in fears to lose lessons
and takeaways if I might bother you
my cardi told you learned it you could
you get 6% raise six-and-a-half
I mean well but désolée the average so
like so what do you think Oh other than
the fact you learned you want to be an
awesome hey
I mean festivals pointers would made me
think about you know the wise son
decisions are made I mean I was at let's
just say an unnamed big company where
all day long people would go into
meetings there'd be no agenda it would
talk for an hour
there'd be no action items taken people
walk out of the meeting and it's as if
the meeting didn't happen it's kind of
like why so we don't have very many
meetings in my companies we have a 12
minute weekly All Hands meeting on
Monday and we have one-on-ones you know
have 30 minutes between me and each
other direct reports and that's about it
so so there's a lie you gave some
examples of the problems that that you
saw in our companies but were there any
things you took away from that that were
valuable to you in your entrepreneurial
career I think that's the question um so
one thing to do is watch executives how
they run meetings what they do what they
are paying attention to and the best way
to do that is to get to know their admin
if the admin knows and likes you you've
got access to the executive so and don't
be shy you know go and ask them all your
dumb questions how do you run meetings
and why what kind of me so those types
of access to people that when you come
out of that company you will not have
access to the other thing I learned was
the decision-making process in a big
company so if you're searching for a
partnership with an AOL what you want to
do is understand how AOL works inside so
that if you have a notion of what a VP
looks like and what type of decisions in
this
company they concern themselves with
what a director looks like what a
manager looks like then when you're
facing them you speak to their concerns
you're not speaking out of context if
you will their contacts lots of lessons
about you know effective meetings as
well as non effective meetings again
depending on the executive defense
depending on how the meeting was run and
then the whole idea that you know how do
you make a ship move when there are
thousands of people involved and are
there any lessons that can be taken from
that to apply to a small company so yeah
I think it was a really rich environment
oh one last thing
lots of training classes and so forth
available in large companies come to a
small company there is none of that you
have to beg your boss you know can I
please go for this $200
you know entrepreneurship conference or
whatever the answers in my company no
and so so you know benefit from those
because larger companies are more
accommodating yeah I start my career at
Morgan Stanley and I went through the
analyst training program there and I
learned excellence work product and how
to just get stuff done and it was just
you're like okay Friday 4 o'clock
MD calls and says are going to go see a
client on Monday we need to build this
gigantic model and run these 50
different scenarios and by the way there
better not be any mistakes and have it
printed bound and at my office at my
home in Westchester by 7 a.m. Monday and
and I just remember there at Morgan
Stanley they taught me once like hey the
difference being good and great is 10
minutes and so what do you mean by that
okay so you do something and you're
going to go give it to a senior guy
Morgan Stanley print it out put it on
your desk go walk around the block go
get a cup of coffee come back and then
read it again and you'll find for
mistakes if you print it out and take it
to them and put it on his desk he'll
find them for you and or she will find
them for you and big companies that are
that maintain a culture of excellence
and execution can really teach you how
to be very personally effective and to
learn to functionally execute very
quickly like build this DCF now and do
this or do that and so Morgan Stanley
Goldman Sachs those are companies that
are big companies but they're
high-performance companies were they a
lot of good work gets done I remember
joking like you know those army
commercials we do more by 6:00 a.m. the
list people all do all day I used to say
that you know I'd go down to the lobby
of Morgan Stanley in New York at 5:00
p.m. and it won't be going home and be
like all right shift is about to start
let's go back up and crank some more
stuff out you like you know how you
learn to work and that I take I took
that away for sure so some of you have
probably worked for or working for large
companies I think I think one of things
you should do is take from that that
there's things to learn and it can be
important to you as an entrepreneur 15
years ago certainly 20 years ago but
even 15 years ago if you asked a venture
capitalist in Silicon Valley what was
the right profile for an entrepreneur
they wanted to back it would be you know
five or ten years at hewlett-packard or
some other company to learn these life
lessons you ask them now they don't say
the same thing and the reason why is
because you have people like these three
people here you can go to work for an
entrepreneurial company and you can
learn these lessons because you have a
set of managers in there who really are
really excellent and can teach you that
other other questions right here
and I don't learn sales I didn't go to
business Jane
I love themselves well you try sewing
how do you get in there well on sales
let me just reinforce what your panel
will set here you think about this so
you you have a company and you're
generating revenue and it comes time for
a vacation so who do you want to go on
vacation let's say you're going to take
a month vacation
could you get by with the marketing
people gone for a month could get by
with the finance people gone for a month
the only people you couldn't let go for
a month or sales and operations you got
to ship the product you gotta have
someone to sail it to sell it all right
so it is it is really important now your
question is how do you get a chance to
do that is that right
a telemarketing for everyone that were
you
really that's only one kind of sale
right yeah right so let's get the panel
I have a tea answer for you i I think
any company you work for as an engineer
would welcome an opportunity for you to
sit on help desk in my company I'm on
help desk at least one once a week at
least for a couple of hours you'll
answer emails and technical problems or
issues people are having using your
product and so forth and then through
answering those you will learn how you
can shift their perception of the
product that's like step number one in
sales you don't have to necessarily get
dollars in exchange but you helped the
company maintain that customer right so
if you're an engineer best place for you
would be to sit on helpdesk and do it
and offer yourself and I knew wherever
you're working people will jump at the
opportunity because you know you have
the technical know-how you'll learn a
lot that way then tag along to the
salespeople as as the expert right they
always know how to sell but they may not
have as much in-depth knowledge of the
product as you do so just ask them you
know hey take me with you next time you
go on a sales call I promise not to open
my mouth or if this is a really hard
customer that has technical problems
tell me what they are and I'll come
prepared to answer those I think that
the first step is just observation I'll
also say that when I was an engineer I
wanted more money and so I looked around
at AMD and I saw sales people making a
lot of money so I said I want to go be a
salesperson so I went and applied and
they told me what you're an engineer go
back to your corner what do you mean you
want to be a salesperson you're an
engineer sit there and that was the
reason why I applied to business school
because I thought okay in my limited
worldview if you wanted to say you have
to go to business school only to learn
that there's really no selling happening
in business
but so anyway there are avenues if we
now have a sales course yeah okay yeah
now this this course was created because
I was teaching a class on Netflix and
Reed Hastings the founder was in the
class and John morgridge was there and
so John asked the question he says how
many and also there were Frank Quatro
and who was the guy who took them public
and the lawyer who took them public
so John asked a question he says how
many people in the in this room have
been in sales and so one person raised
his hand John none of the students
raised their hand so he looks at Frank
what roan says what are you doing these
days Frank and Frank sort of looks at
him says oh I get it raises his hand
okay and of course Reed Hastings a CEO
raises his hand the only person doesn't
raise him as a lawyer sitting over there
thinking goes so John walks over he says
so what do you doing he stays neelix
item says Oh raises his hands so we went
we left that meeting and went to the
wood out and decided that class and
decided we needed a sales course so we
have it now I know how many of you
students have taken it or thinking about
taking it and this is something that
that I think a lot of students are
taking advantage I think we have four
sections this year so that's great
anything else on this question presented
you'll be Singapore a question for you
guys because so far been hearing - yes
shreya cycles inside
so I've been running my company for
about nine years now have you guys had
any experience a lot of people that help
to be in a start-up in India that is for
meetups either or 50 class 60 people
online nine ten years different probably
founders or people is get tired at all
be patient and start and then how do you
handle that Mike on your shirt ah that's
one of the reasons why I like to sell my
company in two years I think there's
there's all sorts of benefits you get
from exponential growth from valuation
standpoint when you're raising
additional financing from a valuation
standpoint when you're selling the
company from an employee morale
standpoint you know literally if you
show these exponential growth of any
metric then everyone's so excited every
weekly meeting by how the numbers up you
know I think it's really hard to have to
maintain the intensity and drive over
the longer periods of time I think there
are different sets of people there are
certain sets people who they couldn't do
it I mean I couldn't do it and I guess
the only other comment I have is I
sometimes advise startup companies and
they say oh yes you know I engineering
teams feeling a little bit you know not
driving as hard they're you know they're
leaving early and whatever and how do I
get them to work harder and a lot of
times I say that's the wrong question
question is that the problem isn't what
they're doing now the problem is who you
got in the couple in the first place
it's a little bit simplistic but I think
it comes down to the questions you ask
during interviews and the type of people
you get in the first place so you may
want to consider switching the team out
to people who are you don't have to
worry about sort of motivation and drive
issues that they're it's so much
internal part of them that it's not an
issue for for you
Greg you adrianna well I was just going
to say I'm I'm the anomaly the room
because I'm a soft drink company and not
a software company but RIA Sales another
thing it's been very much a part of what
we've been doing and more important part
of courses the next session lunch I'm
going to which is on angel investing
because we're at the state or buddy but
I think that there are so many companies
out there that were there are
opportunities to get sales experience it
doesn't necessarily need to be in your
particular field key organize one
consider one half the size is that you
go out and get any kind of sales
experience and you can apply that to for
instance if you're in engineering and
you can apply that same learning
area so I was wondering whether any of
you in your career sale and everything
has been technology focused obviously
because where we are but have you had
experiences in their lives that have
taught you that sales experience or the
for marketing I remember working for an
entrepreneur and he told me that every
CEO has basically two jobs to sell and
raise money and in so I've had to I've
been CEO twice now and I basically my
view is like you know I've subscribed to
Marc Leslie's philosophy of this is like
crack the sales code the formula for
sales yourself get Renaissance people
that are not typically functionally
aligned in any one area but they can do
everything and work out the process for
how you sell and as soon as it's
starting to be codified and repeatable
then you can bring in you know execution
people who are expert at kind of
discipline and so I think that's been my
approach to make the first five or six
sales relies what works what doesn't
work and then as soon as I feel like you
know what this is kind of we got it
then then you can go hire someone who's
literally their resume says sales person
you say okay here's the sales process
here's the collateral here's your number
let's go do it together three or four
times then like launch them off and so
just that's that's kind of what I did
yeah there you go yeah now they know
they don't say that anymore because the
because the people who are running
startup companies often have the same
kind of experience and they're
sophisticated so you can learn from them
they don't say don't do it but it used
to be that's exactly that's the path you
know we want to invest in you at Kleiner
Perkins unless you've been at HP for ten
years not quite like I did you see what
when he went to give a talk in San Jose
no they said no one over 30 yeah
seriously that's what he said and he got
a lot of trouble for it but Sequoia that
they were quoted as saying what Sequoia
is it we don't want are you guys a
majority so I was like well okay Sequoia
like Mike Morris told me the other day
that that he doesn't believe in market
research so what do you mean you don't
believe in market research he says says
the individual entrepreneur has to
understand the market so well and have
you know the million other people that
are just like him or her or us we're not
going to invest in them so that's that's
I would say an extremum yeah definitely
uh let's see we had one here anybody
else right up here so you all have kind
of a long-term spirit around using
several cycles to like comment on the
opportunity
with this specific period in time the
economy and I see a black model that is
mainly broken wing
or race
I I I would say that one of the big jobs
is the mnsure business of course
everyone's talking about is there's a
surplus of committed capital and there's
no public market emiting exits are
challenged and so you have the situation
where the median IT exits like 50
million bucks and you know most the
average company is raising our median
companies raising like 18 million or
something so like how is the math work
so I would say well there's this rise of
this new like the Mike maples the first
round the true ventures founders fund
there's this whole new class of
investors though that are trying to be
super capital efficient Y Combinator
probably the best example of that and so
I think that combined with huge
differences in the cost of operations
you know the rise of Amazon ec2 s3 the
ability to not own a single machine and
run a pretty big web application so I
think the rise of capital fishin see and
and in in a new class of investors whose
expectations are slightly different and
someone has got an 800 million dollar
committed capital fund it's pretty
interesting and it makes it possible
especially if you're in a software a guy
to be very capital efficient and find
access to capital where people have
expectations where a 50 million dollar
exit is actually part of their model I
analyze something else if yeah I think
every interaction now is so dependent on
email that there will be a shift towards
actual customer support and customer
service so to the extent that you can
have more hand-holding you can have a
more complicated product that's
web-based not just rely on user
experience for that and how you train
these people to help you and what
technologies they use I think that's
going to become a very rich environment
you know the whole idea of customer
support and customer education I think
we'll see a renaissance
tagging along all the things that will
set like us on the side I think you
should ignore whatever macro economic
trends are around I think sir there's
disadvantages with in some situations
because it's hard to raise money but
there's counterbalancing positive
advantages these either hire or retain
people now it's easier to get cheaper
office space now and the competition is
lower because I can't get funded so I
really think you should ignore macro
things and just build your company and
just not worry about it
I think we're going to close with that
thank you very much
van wie nice meeting you